your body your choice yeah how come you
didn't say that two years ago how come
he said that the last two years which is
kind of what you were talking about why
the hypocrisy so you're then noticing
the level of hypocrisy on both sides
that comes out with arguments like this
and the lack of consistency
and you see leaks in arguments you only
want your body your choice when it
favors you but you don't want your body
your choice when it doesn't favor you
because you want everybody to take the
vaccine what happened to your body your
choice that's my body i don't want to
get the vaccine you better get about you
don't care about my health dude it's my
body i'm going to do whatever i want to
do my body why are you forcing me to do
it and then the part that i have a
challenge with in regards to abortion is
i don't want to pay for it
if you went and got had sex unprotected
sex nobody told you to not use a condom
you chose i feel better when i have
unprotected sex no problem
it's your choice i don't care i'm just
not paying you abortion you pay for it
you want to get an abortion you go in
and pay for it i'm not going to pay for
it